hello there my name is markiplier and
welcome to another impossible let's play
this time featuring the ice bath
challenge I will be taking these bags of
ice
putting them in this bathtub and then
stepping in alright Bob just don't you
work ever saying some anesthetics leave
you oh you don't have any anesthetics
well that's just bad luck for you yes
I'm trying to cut off your mask with a
toothpick I don't know why
then I'm going up called the impossible
in place it's heart rate with a little
high eyes so I needed to calm it down
lisam mass per good talk Harvey and
right
that's why I want to get out now but I
need to do my outro and I'm really
hoping that we're still recording are
watching please leave a like down below
and I'm not getting out of a tub until
you help me
it's together ready for a lot sec and as
always I will see you in the next video